Mario Molina helped to discover the link
between CFC emissions and the depletion
of the ozone layer this experience has
made him optimistic that science and
politics can come together to solve the
energy problem
Robert Laughlin is much more skeptical
he believes economic forces may make any
political solutions impossible we've not
met I think Bob Laughlin there's a huge
prospect for fusion but I think what you
can learn from the past and from
Fukushima vision which laureate will our
young scientists agree with how do we
convince people that the energy problem
of 2020 of 2050 are crucial now we can't
just wait until 2019 to resolve a 2020
issue to solve the problem you have to
put a price on emissions that is you
have to charge more for energy to induce
the other uses because they are not yet
by the stream many people in society are
sort of very reluctant say to pay more
for gasoline in the United States so if
a politician say ok I'm gonna raise the
price of gas it's like political choices
what it makes sense we have to ask the
question why is the price of oil what it
is we're using too much you know that's
a non-sequitur the price of oil is what
it is because we're using too much it's
not true it's supply and demand ok so
it's people who have drill for the oil
they've got it and now they charge the
most they can to make the most profits
well why can't you just pass laws that
fix the price well you just can't fuel
is more or less twice as expensive and
Europe as it is in the States and but
think about that a minute you'll see it
can't be if you have a internationally
competitive industry like Airlines it
cannot be so that Lufthansa is paying
twice as much for its fuel as United
Airlines because it's a fuel intensive
industry and if you double the price
they'd go out of business so it must be
so there's an
exception there's a byline in the
European in the EU laws specifically
exempting Airlines from from high prices
of fuel you're describing what I call a
market failure of course it's oil is
cheap you can just take it out of the
ground so of course it's gonna be hard
to compete with that Solar is coming
down in price but not fast and open sir
so that's why to fix a market failure
we're talking about government
intervention but it has to be a global
agreement all the countries agree and
it's done it's so principled it couldn't
be done for it of course it's extremely
difficult well
the point I was trying to make is that
it isn't possible that's just wrong the
energy problem is an engineering problem
you must put on an engineering hat and
solve it and that's different from
passing laws to change economics he is
more interested in using legislative
process to pass laws that regulate
people's behavior so he wants to
regulate I want to engineer that's the
difference if the price of these
alternative energies doesn't come down
fast enough there has to be some sort of
international agreement which directly
or indirectly compensates for this
market failure
are you folks at all concerned about the
future of your progeny most most
certainly so let me float a question now
how long before the fossil energy runs
out how long is that consumption yes no
no you're you're evading the question
now just guess you say 100 years that's
the rough estimate so plus or minus 300
okay now let's do worst-case scenario
everyone fails the hundred years comes
Dan fossil energy runs out then what I
think no no I got that this is not an
aloud answer okay because as you know as
you know the way of politics is the
worst possible solution is almost always
the solution to get ok so it's not an
unreasonable question to ask what is the
consequence do you think that needs to
happen we do have precedence it doesn't
have to you know if I may put in that
statement is false if you cut down on
the fossil fuel yours by 20% which is
almost unthinkably hard but if you do
that it merely takes 20% longer to burn
it all up so it's running out is not a
crazy thing to think about so I'm gonna
press you to the wall and ask what
happened we will be forced to come up
with another solution and we always have
as an industry we you mean magic will
happen no I think research what happened
research has happened let me remind you
that research does not make energy
energy is conserved research only makes
papers right now it would have to be
nuclear so it depends how soon like
nuclear and some of the renewables I
mean we do have what happens when the
nuclear runs out more time and then
we're
and biofuels and other things it's true
we do have to face the reality that we
have limited resources so we do have to
think about when fossil fuel runs out
however in tandem we also need to be
proactively working on dissolving up
renewable energy sources and what I also
liked a lot about his contribution was
that it's not really a question of
whether you believe in global warming or
not but that you just have to accept
this limitation of the resources so that
was I think a very clever thing to get
emotions out of this and just to say
okay but we know it's finite so what do
we do there's an idea that I'm trying to
get the flow to the table here usually
when human beings don't have enough of
something they fight now it's not just
historically the way we are okay
now just imagine what happens if the
second most important thing in all the
world after food becomes in short supply
what happens and we're talking about
highly advanced technical fighting okay
and who's gonna be doing this fighting
not me I'll be dead not you probably you
will but your great great great gen
children will be forced to make a
terrible choice whether I'm going to
protect my family or whether I'm going
to let the other people win and usually
people put themselves first so the point
is if you're thinking about saving the
future it's your children that are at
stake that's the issue on the typical
that is supremely important namely that
the possibility that when the transition
happens there will be terrible struggles
and people will die I personally think
that's a more imminent problem than
destroying the world now other people
have different views but I think that's
the big one there are optimistic and
pessimistic views civilization on the
oven on the other hand has been
advancing were much better off of course
there are many difficulties but we have
solutions at hands solar energy of
course it's more expensive but not so
much more expensive but civilization has
to come to an end or to fight and so on
it's clear if you do the calculations it
paid
a small piece of the Sahara Desert to
power the entire planet what you people
of course have to work very hard to do
this precisely to avoid this alternative
which I don't think is it's unavoidable
yeah I think this time is especially
crucial because so many of the developed
countries we've actually been using
about the same amount of energy for a
while but it's really the developing
countries that their energy is
skyrocketing but we have this knowledge
and they can sleep some of those phases
they have solar panels in soccer balls
you know they're not starting with the
grid Oh soccer balls making energy with
soccer chicken I'm really pleased to
hear Tom but I don't want to hear silly
things okay this stuff is deadly serious
if you come up with some crazy science
fiction non non nonsense number four the
Joule budget of the world what you're
gonna have is war this is serious now
right now we are rich because
civilization discovered how to take
energy out of the ground our wealth is
energy it is a non sequitur to say that
we will continue to be rich after the
fossil fuels are gone there's no reason
at all to believe this but how much more
expensive is solar economy spawned I'm
sorry but I disagree with that the
Economist external many others they are
talking about the cost of replacing that
being one or two percent of global GDP
it's in the noise the the economy will
double or triple so the consensus among
people that would look very carefully at
this it's definitely possible this is
nonsense the consensus among people who
make energy who make our lives is that
solar energy is nonsense that's why they
don't invest in it this is wrong but
they would be economy then economists
are idiots
they don't make energy they just sit
around making theories the people who
make energy I escaped from Seville and
there's a big solar concentrated solar
power plant and they sell that it's of
course more expensive what they are
making photovoltaic cells in such a
large scale
they claims no cheaper than concentrated
solar power so the cost of solar energy
is not that far from the cost of fossil
fuel and the difference in cost between
solar energy today and fossil fuel is a
minor fraction of the overall economy
I trust that young people like
yourselves work together with other
young people and these complications
with the economy and so on if you're
clever enough you can actually deal with
them and we do have positive examples we
do have things that upward picked us up
and we have things that have failed
terribly find them out and make sure
they don't happen again
we're in your situation as dire as
McLaughlin described it to me will we be
going to war in the next hundred years
over resources I think it's important to
realize that there's that possibility
because energy is such an integral part
of our lives we need to do where that
and how important it is but use our time
to do the research and make sure we're
making advances in energy so we don't
get to that point the pessimism is
making the students think hard about
some very important things that aren't
abstract trouble in the future when the
world's energy supply gets tight now
what I believe is probably more
optimistic I think people can solve
problems but they won't unless they're
scared so I want to scare them and then
they'll fix it I like the more positive
attitude of Molina you know the
pessimistic picture may be good to raise
attention and to raise the awareness for
an issue but to get to solutions I think
it's it's more interesting to look at
possible solutions and not to paint
everything in black maybe but I think
the future is bright I don't agree with
dr. Laughlin that it's so pessimistic
and that people will go to war over
limited resources yes we will always
fight because people will always
disagree but people certainly have also
shown in the past that we get together
to solve the larger global issues